the Pythagorean theorem tells us that if
we have a right triangle that let me
draw this right triangle that the sum of
the squares of the shorter size of the
two legs so let's say that the length
here is a the length there is B that the
sum of their squares a squared plus B
squared is equal to the square of the
length of the hypotenuse so if the
length of the hypotenuse is C this is
equal to C squared what I want to do in
this video is really just apply the
Pythagorean theorem to figure out the
sides or the missing sides of different
right triangles so in each of these
three examples these are clearly right
triangles and they've given us two of
the sides and we're going to use the
Pythagorean theorem to figure out the
third side so right over here let's see
we have a right triangle they give us
two sides length four and five and you
might be tempted to say 4 squared plus
five squared is going to be equal to C
squared but you need to realize that the
four is one of the legs the four is one
of the legs but the five is the
hypotenuse it is the side opposite the
90-degree side so five in this example
is actually C so if we call this four
maybe we could call this we could call
this B or a we actually get 4 squared
plus B squared is equal to the
hypotenuse squared is equal to 5 squared
so you get 4 squared plus B squared is
equal to 5 squared and I really want to
emphasize that we knew to put we knew
that the C was 5 or that 5 is C is the
hypotenuse because it's the side
opposite the right angle and so we're
actually solving for one of the legs
here so you get 16 plus B squared is
equal to 25 if you subtract 16 from both
sides you get B squared is equal to 9
and then B if you take the principal
root of both sides you get B is equal to
3 we obviously don't care about the
negative root because we're talking
about distances or measurements so it's
B is going to be equal to 3 in this
example right over here now let's do
this one
once again clearly a right angle they
give us two sides and these two sides
are the legs the one that we were trying
to solve for is actually the hypotenuse
the hypotenuse is not given remember the
hypotenuse is the side opposite the
right angle that's the one that's not
given so
this time we actually will be solving
for C so we could call this C right
there that's the length of the
hypotenuse so we're going to get 9
squared plus 7 squared is equal to C
squared 9 squared is 81 plus 7 squared
is 49 and that's going to equal C
squared 81 plus 9 81 plus 9 gives us 90
plus 40 is 130 so we have 130 is equal
to C squared and so C is going to be
equal to the principal root of 130 and
we can see if we can simplify that a
little bit more I'm going to do a prime
factorization of 130 to see if we have
any perfect squares inside of it so 130
is the same thing as 2 times 2 times 65
which is the same thing as 5 times 13
and so it actually does not have any
perfect squares in it you can't simplify
it any more so we just say C is the
square root of 130 and then finally we
have this one over here once again
clearly right triangle
they've given two sides and we have to
make sure that we're solving for the
right thing so the two sides have given
us they've get one of them is the
hypotenuse it is the side opposite the
right angle so they've given us the
hypotenuse they've given us the they've
given us the C in this example right
over here that's 4 square roots of 2 so
this is one of the legs and then we're
gonna have to solve for the other leg
and that's going to be equal to this leg
squared plus this leg squared is going
to be equal to the hypotenuse squared so
we could say let's call this let's just
call this a we can call it a or B or X
or whatever we want to call it but we
can write a squared plus 4 squared is
equal to 4 square roots of 2 squared and
so you have a squared plus 16 is equal
to 4 squared is 16 times 2 right square
root of 2 squared is 2 16 times 2 which
is equal to 32 and then we can subtract
16 from both sides
so if we just if we just let me just
rewrite this a squared plus 16 is equal
to 32 subtract 16 from both sides you
get a square
is equal to is equal to 16 take the
principal root of both sides you get a
is equal to 4 so this is an interesting
one right over here this is actually a
right isosceles triangle this length is
4 this length is 4 right over there but
it's also a right triangle so this is if
you have an isosceles right triangle
like this if the two legs are 4 the
hypotenuse is 4 times the square root of
2